one thing I have noticed is that I don't
know if it's if you guys feel this on
your end but you feel like having a
social media presence even as an actor
is like as like more and more important
now as like than it used to be because
it's certainly important or getting more
important now in the Japanese side of
things oh interesting yeah like some of
the top voice actors now have such a
massive like social media presence and
there's a lot of people who get to know
them not just from the roles that they
do but also from just like what they do
on Twitter or like Instagram or like
even on YouTube
yeah
huge on Twitter yeah okay 50 50 I swear
some some voice actors here say yeah
it's really important are the same I
don't think so what do you think
I have an answer but I'm curious what
your thoughts are I think it's
undeniable that having a large presence
would would put your name kind of in the
face of Moby whether it would lead to
you actually getting more stuff I feel
like that's up to you and how much work
you're putting in yeah sure sure but I
feel like it's definitely gonna put you
in front of people more yeah I think
that's that's fair to say yeah
definitely I think just like now that
everyone is using it no no there's no
correctly the three-friendly questions
like you tell me yeah Mr interviewer
like tone like I'll judge uh I think I
have a more complicated like answer for
it because I do agree with you that um
having a bigger following just people
knowing who you are is that's good right
yeah whether it's for networking whether
it's for just even getting introduced to
things or whatever is good
um but uh for I think there can also be
kind of a stigma oh yeah towards um it's
like the idea of like oh you you're a
YouTuber and you're trying to be a voice
actor like there's definitely been I
mean I will say one there was one
project I recorded for uh and then the I
was working with one director the other
director
found out I was like a big YouTubers
like you put a [ __ ] YouTuber and uh
took me out really really yeah yeah this
happened I won't say the name of it but
uh also that guy was a [ __ ] anyway
but
like I never worked with him but I've
heard he's just a [ __ ] so anyway
yeah that was one instance where
um I went in I recorded uh and was I
lost the part because this guy was like
that's [ __ ] up yeah so I mean that's
that was only one time right um still
the fact that I even happened yeah it
still it's still very I mean and you
you'll you'll see like um on Twitter on
Twitter there'll be like backlash like
oh well so and so they just put them in
because they're and it's like no like so
and so has been you know working hard
towards that goal for a long time and
it's like you know also if any
um anyone who actually gives a [ __ ]
about the art that they're making yeah
they want the performances to be good
right yeah so they're not gonna hire
someone just for or just a cloud just
for the cloud right that's something
you're going to see in like maybe like a
big Hollywood movie yeah when you see
like you know cameos or whatever like
that but for you know stuff where you
actually have to audition for it or
whatever like right
um it it it's completely ridiculous to
say that like oh so-and-so is only
getting it because of this because if so
and so is bad at acting yeah first off
everyone's gonna be able to tell right
when it comes out yeah exactly yeah and
there have been instances where like
sometimes somebody it comes out and
you're like yeah
but um yeah so there's that the whole
like sometimes people kind of
judge you or go all right you shouldn't
be in this or whatever
um like I there have definitely been
times where I feel like I go in to the
booth uh and they don't know who I am
but they saw I guess they like looked by
name up and that's how there was a
YouTuber like and this guy really you
know can they really
and then I like do it and I'm like oh
okay you can do it okay which is absurd
to me because you know a lot of voice
actors come from like stand-up comedy
backgrounds and yeah it's like you had
to start somewhere right like you don't
come out of the [ __ ] womb a voice
actor yeah yeah yeah but for some reason
everyone thinks a YouTuber is just like
well okay that's just a bunch of clowns
man I think we're brainless clowns which
some of us are yeah I get it but you
know it it's also kind of unfair to
completely dismiss someone yeah of
course just because they're they're that
also uh if a big social media presence
was all it took to be cast in something
I will say frankly there would have been
I would have booked a lot more other
things that I was like really close to
right right there have been projects
like where I was like the runner-up
right I was either runner-up guy or in
the last three or whatever right yeah um
and in the end uh they pick whoever they
think is the best fit right yeah if it
was frankly just like that guy's got big
Twitter numbers we want the Twitter
numbers it's like if that was alone the
deciding factor then I would have gotten
it right um which is like kind of a
position of like it's kind of nice and
like at least I'm not being like just
you know thought of as a number but I'm
also like I wanted that part
so but it's like also reassuring of like
oh but you know it's not because of what
some yeah [ __ ] reason that whatever
reasonable followers than you yeah yeah
um but I also feel like for me I don't
get a lot of that backlash yeah for some
reason I don't know maybe because I've
been doing it for so long or whatever I
think it's like maybe the first time a
YouTuber who's also maybe uh like joined
starts doing voice acting maybe the
first time they maybe get a little bit
yeah yeah uh I think it's also just
because you're genuinely good
yeah
good then yeah I can see where the
backlash is coming from right I mean I I
appreciate that yeah and uh yeah I think
it would be clear if you know you can
tell or something yeah
exactly exactly I occasionally got the
comments of like oh it's pretty good for
a YouTuber everyone was like and then
again people would reply he's literally
has like voice actor in his name so it's
like 10 years right
yeah it's weird because like sometimes
when you do YouTube especially when
you're like more revolving around skits
and comedy stuff you forget that you
know you you are able to do you know
serious voice acting as well and your
skill sets just are more broad than just
haha funny getting on the Internet sure
but it's like sometimes hard to change
or change the perception of that
especially to your audience as well I
mean even live action actors deal with
that right like a lot of comedic actors
who try to switch the dramatically like
oh I can't take him seriously yeah yeah
it's like people like to put people in
the boxes right yeah you do this and
only do that funny man or do this and
don't even think you know which can be
reductive yeah I mean like yeah speaking
of like live action acting you've done
that as well with uh you how was the
transition from my voice acting to doing
something like was it anime yeah yeah
yeah yeah no um this is the is it the
Crunchyroll this is the crunch roll
Freddy W yeah Rocket Jump what was the
what was like the plot of this thing
again uh the plot of anime crimes
division is uh we live in uh Neo otaku
City and we are detectives who solve
anime crimes it was very fun we did two
seasons of it yeah um yeah that was like
a big crazy experience for me because I
had had no real live action experience
prior to that and it was definitely like
a crash course but I was fortunate in
that I was with like the most welcoming
crowd of people like I'm friends with
Freddy already yeah yeah yeah I I told
him like frankly like he I I wasn't even
living here yeah I flew out to do it the
first season and I was like
are you sure I'm gonna be okay for this
and he's like he'll be fine like he was
like I'm not you'll be great and it it
honestly worked out like it was super
challenging yeah probably like one of
the most like challenging things I've
done like you know there's so I was the
lead in it and there's so much dialogue
so yeah I have to memorize all that
dialogue and uh in the second season I
do a a whole choreographed fight
sequence that's like it that took like
maybe
five six hours to learn and then to
shoot maybe like
even longer than that right so it was it
was definitely like a crazy experience
but I learned a lot of like how you do
you know live action films yeah like
it's your mark I didn't know what like
you know hitting your mark and what does
that mean hitting Your Mark is on a live
action Set uh if you need to land on a
certain spot for the camera they put an
x on there right with tape or whatever
and they're like okay so like when
you're walking up to this guy hit this
Mark and whatever all right then you're
gonna not look at the Mark yeah yeah
it's gonna do as naturally as possible
or um and then you gotta remember your
lines as well and I gotta remember your
lines and do other things yeah like uh
it's definitely a big departure from
voice acting which 90 of the time you
don't have to memorize anything yeah
unless you're doing like motion capture
right and so that all I mean that was a
big help for me because later I did God
of War Ragnarok uh where I had to again
memorize lines that I had written also
because they had had me write for it uh
and and that was
I was doing it and I was like [ __ ]
idiot why did you give yourself so many
lives I have no one else to blame but
why were you writing the lines uh they
asked they they specifically wanted me
to do it oh wow what was the role uh the
character is uh ratatosker uh right uh I
can't say too much because it's not out
yet oh yeah yeah oh wow yeah when you
said God of War of Ragnarok I was like
that's not out yeah it's not out yeah
but but I have announced it like okay
okay yeah yeah okay yeah I'm not I'm not
just casually spilling ndas yeah I was
just like
yeah people know that I have written for
it acted in it and did the motion
capture and awesome and that I uh the
name of the character but okay I don't
think they know anything else right are
you are you allowed to talk about what
kind of a process is to do mocap I can
talk about generally yeah okay yeah
because I've always found that super
interesting how like live action and
then you know I like you see the behind
the scenes of like you know it's like
the last of us the original like God of
War like how challenging is it being on
a set and just having like a bunch of
[ __ ] pong balls on you yeah uh it's
it's definitely yeah the outfit's really
goofy yeah
um for me I had to do these things where
you uh they're like filming you and
before you shoot you do like sort of
like uh motions you're doing emotions
and like making sure the the model is
like on like sync with you or whatever
yeah
um and that's like a whole thing uh you
have to like sometimes you gotta do like
the facial capture as well and they like
yeah giant thing on you yeah
um yeah it was it was definitely like
very like intimidating but
because I had done the anime crimes
Division I just used to like okay just
memorize your lines and yeah just go
through the scene uh and yeah it was it
was very a very fun experience is it
hard to like getting character when the
entire like set on everything is just
virtual no because voiceover often
you're just in a booth oh that's right
like unless you're dubbing anime or
um
like sometimes with cartoons they give
you them the storyboards right
oftentimes like uh in a video game or
something or most things you're not you
have nothing right that you were just
looking at a script so you have to
imagine yourself in it anyway yeah so
actually having other actors to interact
with uh was more helped with the
immersion more than when you're usually
just alone in a booth right I just
remember that you voiced one of the
playable characters in Borderlands 3 yep
I forgot what the name of the character
Flack yeah yeah that was awesome yeah I
was like oh [ __ ] dude everyone knew that
it got announced um it was awesome yeah
that was one of like the I think that
was like the role of like oh like this
is a big yeah well I think before that
they've been like you know it's in the
in Indie stuff and like some things but
that was like the first sort of uh oh
like a lot of people know about this
yeah
yeah so is there like a particular
franchisal series that is like the
ultimate like I want to voice in this
kind of thing and you haven't done yet
do you have one
oh man I feel like if you say it it's a
curse I know that yeah but obviously I'd
love to be in JoJo yeah okay yeah yeah
sure but who knows when for me I'll say
it because I have the same feeling like
I don't it's like a curse if you say it
out loud yeah it's never gonna happen
yeah right right uh it could be a second
yeah no no this is I mean this is the
one that like is very dear to my heart
and it's a Ace Attorney
I would lose my mind if I was in any Ace
Attorney game or yeah anything like that
like because for me that was one of the
things I used to fandom oh yeah I was
like I'll take because they didn't have
voices so like I'll take this character
I'll give them a voice and uh like I did
it so much that like the fan Community
definitely Associates my voices for
characters or some of the characters
yeah so like if I got a chance to be a
part of that that would definitely be
like feel like a full circle like oh man
yeah yeah and like I've been for
fortunate enough that I've had that
experience with like I mean Borderlands
was one where like I played Borderlands
2 when I was a kid and I was like
oh one day I maybe I'll be able to do
something like this never thinking one
day that the third one would be I would
be one of the main characters in it yeah
so I've I've definitely been fortunate
enough to because I'm also a big fan of
this stuff you know I love anime and
video games like Yes actually I often
tell people I'm like sometimes I wish I
wasn't such a big fan because then I
wouldn't be so crushed that I'm like you
know not in player I'm like oh I got to
read for this but oh I'm not in it like
like a lot of the older guards are like
I don't know what this [ __ ] is yeah this
is Japan animation I don't know what it
is I don't play video games with Pac-Man
I don't know I'm like I know what this
is I've been playing this since I've
been like 15 years old you definitely
have that like um
you know attachment to it yeah yeah yeah
get crushed when you don't get these
sunk everything into the other day
uh I think at this point uh you just get
just get used to it yeah I just assume I
don't I'm like yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm
doing it right yeah I shouldn't even got
it and if you get that email sick yeah
just put do that dish and send it I'm
like if if I'll hear back if I get it
yeah right yeah I think the one person
who I've seen get her like dream role
recently and it was weird uh seeing
because I've followed her career like
basically since the beginning with Kira
bucklands oh yeah so you seeing her like
be like the JoJo girl yeah right she
wanted to be yeah yeah yeah and just
like because I remember back she was she
also started on like vaa and just seeing
her career just like uh the program
she recently just voiced Jolene in JoJo
part six and she [ __ ] killed it I'm
like damn man I'm I'm [ __ ] happy for
her because like it's like I'm I've seen
her like progress her career yeah since
since the beginning it's another example
of again like a lot of people who are
working today are like you know they've
just been grinding and working at it
forever you know yeah yeah